Who could have predicted
that one of the Internet's
most elaborate
fandom communities
would begin with a single post
on June 22nd, 2007?
Uploaded on 4chan's
Paranormal X board,
the statute read like
a government case file,
and opened with
a provocative warning:
"Special containment procedures,
"Item SCP-173 is to be
kept in a locked container
at all times."
The entry describes an
animate and malevolent figure,
made of concrete and rebar,
with indications it had been
spray-painted at one time.
It is housed in a large room
with unbarred windows.
When alone,
sounds of stone scraping
can be heard.
It will fill its container
with a mixture of
reddish brown material,
believed to be a combination
of feces and blood,
but the scariest part,
blink and it will kill you.
Although the post would be
deleted a few days later,
the strange entry
sparked the imagination
of the X community,
suggesting the existence
of a secret government
organization
dedicated to collecting
and containing
preternatural entities.
Yeah, that's the perfect
start for worldbuilding.
[spirited music]
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
This strange entry in 2007
was the genesis of
what we now know
as the SCP Foundation,
a spooky, fictional universe
centered around a Wiki that
hosts thousands of posts,
from contributors
across the globe
who contribute to its lore.
SCP Foundation is
crowdsourced folklore
at some of its finest.
And it takes
collaborative fiction
to a whole new dimension.
While it's tempting
to dismiss the SCP
as some crazy
conspiracy website,
the administrators clearly
and frequently acknowledge
that the Foundation
is essentially an art
and creative writing experiment.
In their words, "The Foundation,
"its anomalies,
and everything else
that's been written
about is fictional."
But that doesn't
make it any less fun.
Quite the opposite.
According to the lore,
the SCP Foundation
is a nebulous international
group of individuals,
who identify, capture,
and contain supernatural
and preternatural anomalies,
with the full support of every
major national government.
Kind of like the
"Men in Black" and "Area 51"
meets "The X-Files."
Their official slogan--
"We secure, we contain,
we protect."
Objects like the
malevolent IKEA store,
Shy Guy, The Old Man,
or the endless staircase,
are iconic
to the Foundation's lore.
If you've been on any horror
corner of the internet,
you've probably felt
the lingering presence
of the SCP in games,
short films,
fiction, and fan art.
Part of that is because
instead of being beholden
to copyright and ownership,
which can restrict
a story's ability to adapt,
each SCP universe entry is
part of a collective tradition
that is ever-evolving.
And the lore spreads quickly.
While many people,
rightfully, tend to hold
older legends and folklore
in reverence for their
historical significance
and insights into
evolving communities,
the SCP Foundation
offers something more,
a unique perspective into
how stories and monsters
evolve in real time.
The community is
open to any member
who would like to post.
Most entries are told
through case files,
fiction, written in
a pseudoscientific report style,
that details the special
containment procedures
of the anomaly,
followed by a detailed
description of the event,
object, or entity,
and how it was contained.
Each of these entries
is given a three- or
four-digit SCP number
and brief title.
Some images may be included,
as well as addendums
that contribute to
the understanding
of the artifact,
and how it is
affecting or responding
to its surroundings.
In more recent years,
creative authors have even
produced interactive pages
that evoke all sorts of
real-world technologies.
Unlike many other fictional
supernatural organizations,
the SCP Foundation is
incredibly bureaucratic,
which contributes to
a successful worldbuilding.
Bureaucracy is
something many of us
are all well too familiar with.
And utilizing this common
cultural understanding
allows for
a more-ready entry point
into the Foundation's world.
Supporting this connection
is SCP's rhetorical style,
which mimics classified
government texts,
especially redacted documents.
Common themes can be found
throughout the
Foundation's many entries.
Fear or reticence of technology,
viral communication,
scientific or governmental
failure to control danger,
definitions of sentience,
doppelganger and
hybrid-being anxiety,
but that's just
the tip of the iceberg.
There's Josie, the half cat,
hidden exoplanets
with alien life forms,
a coffee vending machine
that can produce any
liquid on demand,
a strangely helpful,
star-shaped nightlight,
a pool of what
appears to be blood
from which extremely
hostile entities
occasionally exit,
and the remains of
a murdered woman
that cause horrific
deaths and disappearances.
These objects,
along with thousands of others,
are labeled as one
of 11 object classes.
Separated into common
primary classes
and non-standard object classes,
the categories range from safe,
meaning threatening,
but easily and safely contained
with minimal
Foundational effort,
to anomalies that
require massive effort
to be dealt with.
Usually associated with
a world-ending threat.
Objects in this class
cannot be contained,
are indestructible,
and/or are expected to escape.
An object's class is determined
by the informal Locked Box Test.
According to Foundation lore,
most autonomous, alive,
and/or sapien objects,
are, at least, Euclid-class,
meaning, you can
lock it in a box,
but you're not sure
what will happen.
The authors of these texts
are tapping into attention
that exists across
many populations,
fear that our governments
may not be telling
us the whole story,
and raise questions about if
such information withholding
is productive or destructive.
And that's exactly
what the original,
2007 4chan post provided,
a story that taps
into people's fears
and mistrust of the government,
as well as their ability to
contain their secrets safely.
We might not have
known the source
of the original SCP-173
if it weren't for
the online sleuth
dasMaymay, who brought
the original entry
back to the Internet's awareness
after some archive
searching in 2018.
Fans of Dr. Who
may note the similarities
between the weeping angels
and SCP-173.
While this connection
has not been confirmed,
for Dr. Who fans,
this narrative serves
as an extension
of something that already
exists in popular culture,
but brings it
into a larger organization,
and hints at
its real-world existence
by using familiar bureaucratic
language and style.
Administrators of
the Wiki now note
that SCP-173 is
uniquely inspiring,
because it relies on
the fear that emerges
from wonder and possibility,
rather than a jump scare.
The original five large
threads that emerged
on 4chans X Forum
in January, 2008,
dedicated to expanding
the SCP universe,
became known as the SCP Series.
The popularity of the work
was deemed important enough,
or cool enough,
that, on January 19th,
someone made a Wiki
for all of the SCP-themed posts
that began popping up,
so that the content wouldn't
be lost to the ether.
Originally housed on
the EditThis Wiki farm,
anyone at any time
could edit the stories.
Discussion boards
existed for every page.
User, FritzWillie, saw that
stories were being deleted
by the EditThis hosting network,
and moved the entirety of
the community's content
to a WikiDot,
which went live on
July 25th, 2008.
This move introduced a page
rating and comment system,
and moderators were introduced.
Everything was
still open source.
Any user could edit
any post they wanted.
Until someone
created spam threads
and started deleting
stuff en masse.
Longtime users decided to
remove anonymous edits,
and an administration
team emerged.
Eventually, to keep the spirit
of the original SCP Series,
and ensure that the quality
of content was maintained,
banning was enacted,
and more strict editing
policies put in place.
The community's dedication
to preserving the
early work of the genre
is not just something
I appreciate;
it's absolutely crucial
to establishing any
kind of standard
or canon for the genre.
I also think it shows
a really lovely dedication
to the Foundation's community.
The internet can often feel
like a lawless country,
but when it comes to
the SCP Foundation,
rules help preserve
its integrity.
Because most of the
content posted to the site
is allowed to be adapted,
recreated, or reused,
The Foundation's universe
has served as inspiration
for many other creative works.
There was a theater
contribution to the lore,
Welcome to the Ethics Committee,
performed in Dublin,
a concert in Glasgow,
various video games,
a serialized novel in Japan,
and a graphic novel.
While these elements testify
to the widespread popularity
of the SCP Foundation universe,
its primary presence
online seems most important
to its worldbuilding.
The internet is
inherently liminal,
which can make sharing stories
that seem real, but aren't,
more efficient.
The SCP's case-file approach,
and vaguely scientific rhetoric,
blurs the boundaries
between the real
and the not-real,
in a space many people approach
as both permanent and nebulous.
Virtual reality is a ready space
for imagined realities.
But that's not to say there
aren't educational lessons
in the archives of the SCP,
or that they don't
contribute to social policing
and understandings
of deviant behavior.
Like all explorations
into monsters and fear,
it's about pushing
the boundaries
of what scares or unsettles us,
and why.
These elements are even debated
in the Foundation's
discussion boards.
Take something like SCP-1919,
for instance,
a Euclid-class object that
requires a containment perimeter
with a two-kilometer radius,
since it presents as a decaying,
early 20th-century hotel
and converted mansion.
If a human enters the building,
it produces multiple humanoid
replicas of that person,
as well as anything
they are carrying.
For this reason,
personnel cannot carry
body armor or weapons.
These Replicants are
not perfect bones.
They have physical
abnormalities,
like sealed nostrils,
or improper proportions
that mark them as Replicants.
There are enough of these
that after Expedition Two,
when aggressive Replicants
referred to as
SCP-19191 emerged.
There are apparently
enough of these
that they function as
a coordinated ant colony,
made and controlled by
a singular female being.
Any entry is currently halted
until all manifestations
can be expected
to have starved to death.
Okay, there's a lot
to unpack there,
but the hive zombie mentality,
aggressive mob violence,
and mysterious Replicant leader
called to mind many
real-world fears
of overpopulation,
destructive groupthink,
and even urban decay,
giving the buildings
decrepit appearance.
But those are just
my interpretations.
I think that's where
a lot of the real genius
comes from
in the SCP Foundation.
Just enough
information is given,
and given impassively enough,
that your mind goes crazy,
trying to fill in the blanks.
There seem to be no completed
stories or case files,
which means infinite exploration
of what scares us is possible.
In my opinion,
in some ways, there's
even greater potential
for legend growth,
and significance through
online global communities,
like the SCP Foundation.
They allow stories
to cultivate quickly
and in nuanced ways
that translate
their relatability
across disparate communities.
Telling these stories
is performative,
a form of communication
that allows for others
to offer their own alterations
to the text in real-time.
The appreciation for recreating
and retelling the stories,
without fear of
copyright infringement,
is an interpretive freedom
that's actually really powerful.
It hearkens back to more
traditional lore evolution,
just without geographic
or language boundaries.
While, "We secure,
we contain, we protect"
is their official slogan,
dare I add, "We teach"?
While not an educational tool
by design,
the collaborative format
can advance participants'
multimedia communication skills.
The creative guidelines,
open authorship,
an informal peer review process
covers many
of the fundamental components
of traditional
writing practices.
Invention,
collaboration, drafting,
revision, and reflection,
those all happen
in the SCP wiki.
It embodies storytelling methods
with digital media literacy.
Is it a substitute for
a formal writing course?
ASU professor, Emily Zarka, PhD,
says no.
But it can serve as
a supplemental educational tool,
especially for writers
who may be hesitant
to jump into creative
writing spaces,
or for authors looking
for a community.
Heck, maybe it has
a place in my syllabus.
SCP Foundation is building
and supporting a vibrant
and creative community
that reformulates the
crucial human custom
of storytelling
and lore building.
And it has the added bonus
of being creepy AF.
An anonymity of reports.
Anonymity.
I did it again,
anonymity of reports.
[bystander chuckles]
There's too many Ws in a row.